es ist eines der spektakulärsten
experimente der welt die beteiligten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
der karlsruher neutrino wagen dass
kathrin experimentes haben erste
ergebnisse veröffentlicht und die sind
tatsächlich sehr sehr spannend den
fachleuten gelang es die masse der wohl
mysteriösesten teilchens unseres
universums mit bisher ungekannter
genauigkeit zu bestimmen klicks und
science fiction hier gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktive die glocken nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
dass katrin experiment in karlsruhe wird
oft auch als die genaueste waage der
welt oder das reinste vakuum auf der
erde bezeichnet und die neutrino waage
macht ihrem namen offensichtlich alle
ehre neutrinos sind elektrisch neutral
leicht und die häufigsten
elementarteilchen überhaupt sie formen
galaxien und stecken hinter der bewegung
im universum sie rasen fast mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit durch das all und
hinterlassen dabei so gut wie keine
spuren eines der größten rätsel der
physik lautet wie schwer sind diese
mysteriösen geister teilchen es vor vier
jahren 2015 konnte man endgültig
beweisen dass diese teilchen eine masse
haben müssen vorher ging ein langer zeit
davon aus dass sie quasi masse los sind
nicht umsonst werden sie auch als
geister teilchen bezeichnet denn sie
interagieren nicht mit gewöhnlicher
materie sie rasen statt dessen einfach
durch sehen durch durch menschen häuser
oder auch sterne und planeten irgendwie
unvorstellbar doch ist es tatsächlich so
dass pro sekunde
60 bis 100 milliarden neutrinos auf
jeden quadratzentimeter der erde
einprasseln ohne dass etwas passiert
oder dass dieser neutrino beschuss
beobachtet werden könnte
nur spezielle neutrino observatorien
machen dies möglich große hoffnung bei
der erforschung der mysteriöse neutrino
masse ruht auf den rund 200
forscherinnen und forschern die am
sogenannten karlsruher tritium neutrino
experiment kam trend beteiligt sind denn
vor allem langfristig gesehen erhoffen
sich astrophysikerin und astrophysiker
weltweit durch die
online erkenntnisse endlich die basics
des universums zu verstehen warum gibt
es etwas und warum gibt es nicht einfach
nichts
oder anders gefragt warum ist beim
urknall ein ungleichgewicht zwischen
materie und antimaterie entstanden dazu
der kernphysiker heimischer batzen wenn
man die masse der neutrinos müsste dann
würde man fundamentale fragen in der
kosmologie der astrophysik und der
teilchenphysik beantworten können jetzt
haben die forschenden vom karlsruher
institut für technologie kit erste super
spannende ergebnisse veröffentlicht und
das obwohl erst im frühjahr diesen
jahres die neutrinos das erste mal auf
die super genauer waagschale von katrin
gelegt werden konnten
was nicht heißt dass diese arbeit ein
kinderspiel war im gegenteil die
vorarbeiten dafür dauerten achtung 15
jahre
dazu heißt es auf der webseite vom
karlsruher institut für technologie
das aktuelle ergebnis von katrin baut
auf jahrelangen vorarbeiten auf die
einen rahmen für die datenverarbeitung
geschaffen wichtige störsignale und
unsicherheits quellen identifiziert und
eingeschränkt sowie ein umfassendes
modell des instruments erstellt haben
durch simulation und test messungen
gewannen die analysten ein tiefes
verständnis für das experiment unseren
detail jedes verhalten
doch die ganze arbeit hat sich gelohnt
durch kathrin wissen wir jetzt dass ein
neutrino mindestens 500.000 mal leichter
ist als ein elektron ein partikel weist
eine masse von höchstens 1,1
elektronenvolt auf da laut der
einsteinschen relativitätstheorie masse
in energie umgewandelt werden kann ist
diese einheit auch für die masse möglich
normalerweise wird die einheit
elektronenvolt ja als einheit für
energie benutzt klar ist jedenfalls die
masse der teilchen konnte bisher noch
nie mit solch einer präzision bestimmt
werden die messungen sind nämlich um
einen faktor 2 genauer als alle bisher
durchgeführten laborexperimente die
teils viele jahre gedauert haben
fachleute hatten im vorfeld bereits eine
mindest masse von 0,1 elektronenvolt
festgestellt dass wirklich korrekte
ergebnis wird sich also irgendwo in dem
korridor von 0,1 bis 11
rowohlt befinden doch dafür ist der
versuchsaufbau von katrin auch nicht
ohne tritium ein radioaktives
wasserstoffatom tritt in ein vakuum bei
seinem zerfall wandelt sich ein neutron
in ein elektron ein proton und ein
neutrino dann wird die bewegungsenergie
des elektronisch gemessen daraus lässt
sich dann die energie des neutrinos und
damit auch seine masse ableiten
doch dafür müssen alle anderen
elektronen herausgefiltert werden
dies geschieht durch ein magnetfeld dass
die teilchen durch eine unglaublich 23
meter langer vakuumkammer führt und es
war deutlich zu sagen diese länge
entspricht der eines blau war als nur
die stärksten und schnellsten die
zusammen mit dem nackten und trainer
entstanden sind schaffen ist bis auf die
andere seite zum detektor am ende des
versuchs auf der webseite von pc und da
so beschrieben beim beta zerfall von
trink zum teilen sich das dabei
entstehende elektronen und sein
neutraler hier nicht nachgewiesener
partner das elektron neutrinos die
freiwerdende energie von rund 18.600
elektronenvolt in sehr seltenen fällen
erhält das elektron praktisch die
gesamte energie während für das neutrino
nur ein winziger bruchteil davon
übrigbleibt mindestens aber gemäss
einsteigen dem betrag gleich ma c
quadrat seine ruhe masse dies führt zu
einer sehr kleinen modifikation des
elektronisch spektrums durch die
neutrino masse nach der das katrin team
nun in dem nur wenige dutzend
elektronenvolt schmalen energie
intervall am endpunkt des spektrums
gesucht hat heißt also im klartext dass
tatsächlich kann ich die neutrinos
gemessen werden doch wie sollte das auch
möglich sein wenn sie doch wie geistern
teilchen durch alles hindurch gelangen
gemessen werden stattdessen ihre
begleiter die elektronen nämlich und
noch etwas konkreter
das experiment ist quasi den nackten
neutrinos auf der spur also den
neutrinos die beim beten fall nichts von
der freigesetzten energie abbekommen
haben denn damals weiß wie hoch die
ursprünglich freigesetzte energie war
kann man von der bewegungsenergie des
elektrons eine absolute masse bestimmung
der neutrinos vornehmen die einheit
davor mgv also mit
elektronenvolt kurios wenn man bedenkt
dass der anderen teilchen in einheiten
angegeben werden die vielen milliarden
mal größer sind laut das forschungsteam
zum kec sind diese ersten ergebnisse
bereits ein wichtiger meilenstein dazu
der kt sprecher guido tracks liegen dass
kathrin nach einer messkampagne von nur
wenigen wochen im frühjahr 2009 10
bereits die weltbeste sensitivität für
die neutrino masse besitzt und die
mehrjährigen messungen der vorgänger
experimente um einen faktor 2 verbessert
zeigt das außerordentlich hohe potenzial
unseres projekts der größte erfolg für
die forscherinnen und forscher wäre es
mit hilfe von katrin die genauen masse
der neutrinos zu bestimmen dafür müsste
sie mehr als 200 m ev betragen denn so
viel gibt katrin her dass kanzler
experiment ist laut der expertin
experten vielleicht sogar in der lage
den bereich zwischen 0,1 und 0,2
elektronenvolt weiter einzugrenzen
bisher stecken insgesamt 60 millionen
euro und 17 jahre arbeit in katrin und
einen plan b gibt es sogar auch schon
falls bis zum jahr 2023 noch immer keine
absolute masse bestimmung möglich
gewesen sein sollte dann könnte ein
update von katrin erfolgen so dass sogar
messungen bis 100 m ev möglich werden
doch mehr geht definitiv nicht dazu
schreibt das wissenschaftsmagazin
science grad drin könnte die letzte
hoffnung der physiker sein
die neutrinos wasser zu messen zumindest
ohne eine revolutionäre neue technologie
wahnsinn rätsel um geister teilchen erde
als gigantischer neutrino killer
anklicken anschauen und krieg zum
science fiction abonnieren also diesen
kanal
denn ich habe den verdacht wenn ich mir
so die statistiken ansehen dass eine
menge von euch viel verpassen also abo
da lassen damit er nichts mehr verpasst
bis dann bleibt dran